I'm going to pull up the story with us
from the New York Times The Godfather of
AI leaves Google in warns of danger
ahead for half a century Jeffrey Hinton
nurtured the technology at the heart of
chatbots like chat GPT now he worries it
will cause serious harm
he officially joined a growing chorus of
Critics on Monday who say the companies
are racing towards danger he said he
quit his job at Google where he worked
for more than a decade quote I console
myself with a normal excuse if I hadn't
done it somebody else would have that's
amazing there's they they gave chat GPT
access to the internet access to its own
code and money and it immediately tried
seeking power and deceiving people
one of the things that it did to bypass
captcha was it contacted a a disabled
assistance hotline and said you sent a
message saying I'm blind and I need to
log in can you tell me what this says
and they're like yep sure no problem
here you go and the AI tricked a human
into giving it access to a system
chew on that one
I think I think the AI is I think it
already took over like I don't think
there's anything there's any style I
don't think the law is going to stop it
the there is I the worst thing that I
have heard about uh AGI artificial
general intelligence is the concept that
if it is capable of strategy whoever
develops AGI whatever country develops
AGI first automatically wins any kind of
war that you could possibly come up with
because just like with deep blue like
now that deep blue exists human beings
can are no longer capable of beating the
most advanced chess algorithms so
because people can't because AGI is that
powerful there is an incentive to have a
first strike
if we ban it
China does it and they're probably
already doing it
well I mean don't you think that there's
the ability for it to be researched and
still understood and not what I really
think is the orange man is very bad and
these are the things that are important
to talk about that was the CNN thing
last night we got taught we're talking
about AGI here and the possibility of
nuclear war and stuff and and they're
just it's just so damn frustrating to
think about that sorry
but I think that
they control people through messages
like that I mean they're very powerful
with messages like that and they're
they're very powerful shaming you and
telling you that it's loving to be with
them I mean that's what I'm saying they
frame things incredibly well so they
don't have to talk about this they don't
want you to think about this
I mean it's not a lovely thing to think
about you're like gloating over there
I'm not gloating it's just it's it's one
of those things where it's like it's
it's a real these are real threats and
these are real things that are going on
and these conversations have to be had
right yeah there aren't enough people
having them they're already replacing
jobs with AI like only fans they're fun
oh yeah fake pictures and it's like
probably dudes running the account so I
noticed it's already well then you can't
be a famous instagrammer you can't fans
person you could be anyone two big
things one on Instagram a lot of young
women make money off being influencers
by just posting photos of themselves but
now you can AI generate a character and
have it automatically post three
pictures per day you walk away and it's
generating influence and attention the
other thing that's happened is deep fake
porn where you can take anyone's face
and put it on a woman's body or man's
body and it generates the video for you
it was a huge Scandal I guess on Twitch
or something like that people are doing
weird things with it well that's
happened with a bunch of celebrities
right there it's it's like the Futurama
episode where Fry downloads Lucy Liu
into a mannequin into a robot so that he
can be dating Lucy Liu like that's
really where we're kind of going with it
with the AI and all this stuff I mean if
if if you are capable of creating your
own AI girlfriend why wouldn't you make
it look like your favorite actor or your
favorite actress or whatever or you mix
wouldn't you make a bunch of money off
of her on the internet yeah well here's
the thing too Weird Science morals we're
talking about all this domestic stuff
but let's talk about little things let's
talk about war yeah what happens if this
AI is Unleashed into the US internet
let's say Russia or China or whoever
Builds an AI that can automatically
create social media accounts and
simulate real human behavior on Twitter
10 years ago the U.S Air Force was outed
for creating fake Twitter I think it was
Twitter accounts to influence politics
in other countries they're called sock
puppets one person controls 50 accounts
and they'll you'll tweet something like
well I just think you know taxes are too
high and then they'll say are you nuts
taxes are not high enough the rich
people need to be taxed and they'll log
into next account I agree with him
there's not enough taxes log into the
next account yes you're both right taxes
should be higher one person doing all
that now we have an AI do it and they've
probably been doing this for the past
several years now they can press go and
have an AI and a thousand responses to
your one tweet you might think you're
famous
like Dylan Mulvaney that's just an
algorithm propping up Dylan Mulvaney's
post so Dylan thinks there's people out
there who love me Bud Light proves most
people find Del mulvedi grading and and
and and just unpersonable I'll keep up
keep it a little nice but because Tick
Tock is propping up these videos and
making people watch it or I'm willing to
bet some of them aren't even real people
Dylan is convinced they're doing
something good
like this is what they should keep doing
meanwhile you can see
Bud Light was destroyed because of their
association with with Dylan mulvania I
think I think the AI attacks
weaponization is going to destroy
Society like some kind of mind plague
that comes in and no one sees it coming
or we do see it coming we can't stop it
oh how did you stop it that's the thing
like that's where I'm at it's like
that's why it's kind of like well that's
why I'm fairly black filled on it is I
can't conceive of any way to stop it
because it plays to what people want
like it knows exactly how to deliver
dopamine right to your brain you know
and if if if just a like button and just
a notification hey someone liked
something that you said if that can
affect your behavior so much like that
just that small little thing never mind
a plug right into your brain that can
control your your your uh your dopamine
delivery system come on you like human
beings cannot fight that like there is
no way it's hard because I mean I know
what it was like when I was trying to
quit smoking cigarettes right
nicotineism it like it is a it is
incredibly powerful I can't imagine what
just constantly dumping dopamine
straight into your head like every time
you think the proper thought the
algorithm says look give them a little
pop of dopamine next thing you know you
never think an impact Twitter out again
that's what Twitter is exactly yeah
right we've already seen it I mean
that's how we have influencers if if
that weren't possible we wouldn't have
influencers already but we have them
because people have already gotten that
every time they get that like they get
oh I can do this again I'll do something
different I'll do something more extreme
I'm just so black pilled on people's
ability to resist that because it's if
once you can
plug into someone's head and affect the
way their brain produces chemicals in
the way in a way to make it imitate
experience then people will always
decide to go into that because the way
you experience the world is with your
brain but you still have to make money
somehow how do you make money because
you have to pay for this experience
somebody who is building this to make
money they you will have to pay them to
make money or to be in control well hold
on take a look at somebody who worked at
BuzzFeed news getting paid eighty
thousand dollars a year and the guy who
worked as a an apprentice Tradesman or
Union Tradesman making 50 60 a year
somebody who did no work there were
people at BuzzFeed who did almost
nothing when I worked for vice and for
Fusion I can tell you there are people
who literally did nothing and we're
getting six figures
they made money so you will have the
Haves and the have-nots you will have
the lower class working these jobs
mining Cobalt in Africa or wherever else
mining sulfur to build the machines for
the ultra wealthy chosen class of people
who are in the pods being their own mini
gods in their virtual universes we're
already basically there people in
foreign countries do effective slave
labor for for pennies in the dollar if
that to mine the materials that we can
have our video games our movies and then
while they're doing all that work some
dude gets a job at BuzzFeed and writes
the top 10 reasons why SpongeBob is is
is a a true true truly masculine or some
nonsense and then they'll be like look
how ripped SpongeBob is and they'll show
a picture of SpongeBob flexing that
person's getting 100K a year or some
other crazy amount even if it's 50 or
40K it's like they're getting money for
that
wedding
to death in a field to harvest the the
rare Earths so that somebody can write
about how SpongeBob is you know
masculine or something
we're already there
that's that's that's the sad reality but
why why isn't that the discussion either
when you have I mean you talk about
these These are kids that are mining
it's kids that are mining this is slave
labor it's slave child labor and that's
a discussion we don't have like why do
we think that all of this new energy is
so loving it's not
it's not in the literal sense slave
labor it's it's it's viewed by these
corporations like this you've got an
area of the world with a hundred
thousand people who live there and
they're starving we can give them one
quarter per hour which means they're no
longer starving all they gotta do is
mine that Cobalt for us
are they better off Starving in fields
or doing this job and that's what ends
up happening these companies are like
look we're giving jobs to these people
they're better off now than they were 10
years ago thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time